my small so can move it here with your
cursor
oh is it twisted in or something
I would assume it should be I guess it's
just a matter of pulling it hard enough
have you reflected not yet working on it
okay I'll make sure we use it oh let's
see uh there's really no need to rush
plenty of time there's no need to try to
jump the bandwagon got plenty of time
good I'm at the roll towel now Rosco let
me get the writ tethered on it in the
meantime I'm gonna grab the bag the roll
towel is on the right now that'd be the
one why was it lifted here in the first
place you know it was exposed exposed to
what exactly about that is just that
well in the early days of station we we
were not permitted to jettison towels
that's why we rolled them up and left
them exactly where you're grabbing it
out of now Gargamel can you spread the
bag open a little bit yeah if you spread
it out wide enough then I'll be able to
just toss it in there right away
would you stupid wish you for watching
soccer rolls Portugal oh and just so
happens that this towel has missed a
lunch across name all over it
go come on is it in the bag all right
can I release the red yeah let me kind
of get it in deeper into the bag so that
it I'll tell you one
no condom alig kononenko at the bottom
of your screen wearing the suit bearing
the red stripes and alexey ovchinin and
the suit were the blue stripes jumping
ahead a bit in the timeline and
collecting a towel that has been affixed
to a handrail on these vests de service
module to which the piers docking
compartment is attached that towel has
been outside for several years it will
be brought back inside no longer needed
outside on the International Space
Station's Russian segment
[Music]
thank you click here we get the WVS
video from from you but not from oleg
nothing from me can I borrow a cycle it
again let's try that that group though
he knows me back shot last year
Warners could also Trapani impressive
you what my neighbors remember that
other end of the rent was secure so why
don't you tell her it to it while you're
at it
so the Quixote is not researching otaku
threatening you
yeah when you see it from the inside
it's not at all similar to seeing it
directly to the the Rotel is in the back
in the bag is required this is our first
helmet-cam review this is from alexey
ovchinin s helmet camera designated by
the number 11 in the lower right hand
corner and of course by the blue stripes
on his arms and you can see just a
glimpse of alig Kononenko there on the
left with the suit bearing the red
stripes around
let me get it up to you can I attach it
yes a little bit lower
yeah but if we're about to shoot that
video then maybe not super Cruiser it's
power cycle it turn it off and turn it
back on can you get in closer agree to
go to off on circuit the WVS has been
power cycle the green LED is back on
let's give it a few more and then we'll
have to make final decision on whether
we go to record the mess or not well
this is better than nothing
okay can you get it in kind of inside
Alexia my sphere okay why don't you go
ahead and activate the SPR thermal
control system that way set it to zero
it's in a mid position thermal control
handle is in the mid position activating
the STM a neutral position get bits in
the mid position
kappa guys the Liana's portrait is under
your right arm
the International Space Station flying
253 miles over brasilia brazil the
capital moving from Southwest to
Northeast this view from alexey ovchinin
helmet camera the two cosmonauts soon to
pay tribute to alexei leonov the first
human to walk in space on the occasion
of his 85th birthday tomorrow has been
provided so now we're just a matter of
getting it manifested for planes should
I make a video of myself
there's a difference okay
NEX hey Oleg both channels were getting
wvs video from Alexis camera so here's
the deal
you'll grab the portrait you will get
you some positioned where Alexis camera
can see you and then we'll proceed with
the birthday message allocate in that
case you'll be holding the GoPro give it
are you are you okay but you know let me
hold it yeah the portrait is under your
right hand right hand
right over there Oh Turkey the tailor is
too short
I don't got enough tether to get that
far down you need to pull it in towards
the hedge we'll just bring a cart in
Cibola yeah just about now before alexei
started moving the picture framing was
pretty good we could see about half of
you Olli
ah no not on tell me oh is it already
antenna yeah whistle solution so this is
a proverb I would see you
it's a kind of flying out towards that
way more or less yep sigh portrait the
board portrait and a GoPro let me get in
closer to where you are gaia funny but
can you pull me in a little you try to
get on the foot restraint my god male
get your feet secured yeah don't I don't
think something waste of time
all right I can hold the portrait to
make it a little more convenient well
Sergei Moscow we're ready we've got the
portrait can you see it in the picture
we can see but Wikipedia lets you move
over to your left a little bit
yeah we're shooting GoPro as well yeah
yes sorry should I'm we go to start all
right
Alexei GoPro is way blocking everything
bring it down yeah let Alexei kind of
get his bearings and because the GoPro
is facing the opposite way that it needs
to so let them get in position first
are you ready yes I am it was cute clean
electric move to the left rear straw to
the left of what is real and you turn to
the left to get more Oleg in the frame
yeah like that
we go to start so as all of the world's
eyes are trained on us right now we
would like to take this moment before we
dive into the VA tasks it just so
happened that we are performing a
spacewalk the day before the birthday of
Alexei Leonov the first man to ever done
a spacesuit and venture out of his
spacecrafts airlock taking a step into
the starlit abyss into the vastness of
space this is why we're precisely this
is precisely why were decided to
dedicate today's spacewalk to the legend
of man in this legend women here's a
photo of mr. Leonov though we've brought
with us and position it right next to
the AV letter of the Russian segment
wherever I look here he mr. Liana at
super 3 please accept our heartfelt
birthday wishes Jeff with my man you are
with us here and now in the outer space
use your hands for the entire duration
of this spacewalk you will be here with
us
alaya vehicle stay in great cosmonaut
worthy health we hope you continue to be
happy
inspired and truly capable of many great
new accomplishments happy birthday
he boarded mr. Leonov problem moreover
we do have some special messages
attached to our individual spaces that
you can see and enjoy reading again
happy birthday on this special day well
should we go down now all right guys
this is it get the GoPros back in place
secure
tell us what to do
Aled Kononenko the expedition 59
commander in your view through alexey
ovchinin helmet camera wearing the suit
bearing the red stripes having embarked
on the fifth spacewalk of his career
paying a tribute through those words to
alexei leonov who was the first human to
walk in space on march 18th 1965 a
modest 12-minute excursion outside vasca
2 that he and Pavel Belyayev rode to
orbit testing for the first time a human
capability to operate in the vacuum of
space that has led to numerous hundreds
of spacewalks since including excursions
on the surface of the Moon as well as
the International Space Station 217
spacewalks including today in support of
space station assembly maintenance and
upgrades a good view of the two
cosmonauts of Chinon in the suit wearing
the blue stripes on the left kononenko
and the red stripes on the right
having just paid tribute to Alexey
Leonov who turns 85 years old tomorrow
crew now will press ahead with their
next series of tasks almost all of the
work from this point on to be conducted
up near the poisk module on the zenith
or a space facing side of the Russian
segment of the International Space
Station the next task on the timeline
will be the installation of a handrail
to facilitate movements between poisk
and the zarya module on the Russian
segment the first element launched in
international space station history back
on November 20th 1998
just don't pull it too much Thursday Oh
black dissipation don't feel awesome
escape addiction baby please go ahead
and hook over there yeah it's there just
a little overlapping so we need to move
them away from each other
oh come on that should be good
oh yes please but I mean for good money
and your side is on the right side
meaning the stores of GB so it looks
good
Oh silly but they're still you there I'm
at the Strela boom beautiful course
happy
Aleksei wait for me
very peaceful
this video opening image is actually
first attach the adjustable tether and
and then the short tether no rush
[Applause]
they acquiesced region that bill
creature and I mean if them I remember
your translating all the way to mrm to
using circumferential Henry yeah yes
that's right and then we'll reuse our
each other I did Suja portago
and we simulated this undone so I'm just
going to translate this way to get it
adapted to being outside first okay so
that your copy will not be easier
honey put them Alexi see the lanyard on
the side you can hook a hook to them and
I am using the ring
okay
no idea how to put a punishment right so
can I start translating now yes go ahead
to look to my other party that I'm
stupid on the scrolling we were all
looking at it as in Doug we're supposed
to stay to the left correct yes I think
that would be best way and I am waiting
for your lipstick to get to where I am
okay so what y'all ladies reports in
cooler temperatures was done out of
course a I see the hand roll that we're
supposed to be installing there is a an
identical one already installed copy
good it's a toughie
don't you Risa cure your each other yes
good older man I'm going to continue
translation once it starts to stretch
too much let me know okay what should
that be enough
sure now go ahead and move a little bit
farther okay give me a second okay
yes of any obvious drone is four so can
you prove my mom Sergei there has never
been a spacewalk that I performed that I
wasn't required to use Strela in some
way
oh that's great it was meant to be in
spiritually sorry boo-boo my bloody
sister over yonder gate we're gonna
start translating towards starboard now
and I already see one of the test panels
on the EBA letter we want to install a
shortcut handrail first darkstorm oh boy
okay so we're going towards voice module
correct
diet is by you do story no program yes
you are translating towards FGB where's
the letter K is labeled copy that's what
we thought
where uncle right now copy
addresses all procedures much wiser a
postage
yep economy improvement right and Alexei
if the Sun is too bright you can hold
down your visor I'm I'm good
me too
Oh John so what's going on
people they show him okay so should I
move up some more
yes go ahead
or the difficulty scores and by weight
okay standing by
gurgi Oh Sergei well it's interesting
I do believe God except one so did you
remove the wires here and the antenna
using insulation or initials yes it was
early removed from here just to make
sure that it's not in the way
Kusum okay don't tell Dad
alexander samokutyaev removed to avoid
any units back van okay
Cyclospora Lexi my dream of the I think
their origin predominate from mmm soon
so move over here
stand by
naturally a particular let me go so I'm
going to translate over there
gradually absolutely yes and the tether
is tightened
that she said this is Mission Control
Houston 51 minutes into today's
spacewalk by Allied command Yanko and
alexey ovchinin this view from an
external camera on the International
Space Station showing the two cosmonauts
Kononenko at the bottom and above him is
of Chinon as they make their way down
the Strela boom this is a telescoping
boom that is used to help Russian space
walkers move about the Russian segment
of the International Space Station at
the very bottom of your screen are the
Cyrillic letters that spell out the word
poisk that is the module that is affixed
to the zenith or space facing side of
the Russian segment of the International
Space Station and to which the two
cosmonauts will be pressing ahead with
most of the work on the docket for
today's spacewalk which is the fourth
for expedition 59 and the fourth in this
calendar year with many more spacewalks
in the offing and what will prove to be
if it all pans out one of the busiest
spacewalking years in human spaceflight
history the ring here in the ring on the
way
okay.i to handrail 60 20 and i'm
currently using the two cosmonauts are
about to set up shop in the vicinity
there of the poisk module to install a
handrail that will prove to be a
shortcut for movements between the poisk
module and the Zarya module which is on
the earth-facing side of the Russian
segment of the station
you know go have them to re-engage your
dealer hook again
okay so the handrail is next to your
right shoulder is delicious poor rusev
on a mission for if you look up planet
will be Pharaoh so do you see the
handrail now yes so rope your tether to
that handrail and then you will
re-engage it to the circular handrail
okay so I don't think that I can do it
right away
we're going to do is first around this
album will actually please go adjustable
tether first so to make sure that you
will be able to engage it onto the shirt
okay so let me go back here
so I using the small hook yes that's
correct
oh okay so connects wonderful inaudible
okay okay it is underneath your left arm
I'm holding it and I'm going to get on
to the handrail and then you will move
over to the ear a bundle and you will
take it out from underneath fellow boom
we're gonna be a bundle is attached to
is attached on one side and I'm Adam
Ramsey okay we're having release it
welcome follow okay so I need to put my
shorts tether to the handrail and that's
where we're translating - yes that's
correct
Claire go to garden Robert okay so we
hook is engaged onto the handrail 6020
okay and I need to reach to the group I
was there reach the trend rail okay copy
you will need to re-engage your hook to
this short hand rail and then you will
move over here
Farra gurgles okay your mommy go give me
the other hook it is already engaged
so we'll needs to engage it onto the
circular handrail help in turn it over
the seller actually okay give me a large
book now and I'm going to reengage it to
over here
okay
[Applause]
okay got it yes thanks now you will need
to re-engage let's hook please move in
the vertical direction okay your usual
screen and lower your legs please
or video cooking and move forward
okay it's good now looking pretty much
and you can rehook the eBay bundle just
make sure that is not in the way that we
don't have to carry it all the way there
okay so what can do that some by
this is Mission Control Houston were
approaching the 1 hour mark into today's
spacewalk by Alek kononenko and alexey
ovchinin the 217th spacewalk in support
of space station assembly maintenance
and upgrades the two cosmonauts opened
the hatch to the piers docking
compartment airlock at 10:42 a.m.
Central time 11:42 a.m. Eastern Time
this morning both Chinon was first out
of the hatch setting up equipment
followed shortly thereafter by oleg
kononenko they retrieved a towel that
had been tied to a handrail right
outside of the piers hatch way that was
placed back inside the airlock and then
they paid tribute to Alexey Leonov who
turns 85 years old tomorrow the iconic
Russian cosmonaut who was the first
human to walk in space on March 18th
1965 the crew now as you can see in this
downlink video from an external camera
on the truss of the station is working
in the vicinity of the poisk module on
the space facing side of the Russian
segment of the station as they work to
install a shortcut handrail that will
make a translation path easier to
navigate for the future space walkers
between poisk and the Zarya module which
is on the earth-facing side of the
russian segment
[Applause]
[Music]
so the right one is not tethered and it
is not secured
[Applause]
vehicle beeping today you will have to
translate FGB alexei will translate the
words to be now okay okay copy Oleg and
at 6:15 there is a sensor do you see yes
I think that's it 1505 1606 16 17 is a
90-degree angle approximately division
oh we forgot about these items when we
were planning everything and I
remembered about that yesterday our
cocoa crop cookies well should we
relocate this kids but I don't think
that's possible
because of all the cables here okay you
know really all it we can't relocate it
super didn't I put it there in the first
place okay copy
I mean crush their stupid right three of
them okay Alexi we're going to be at
eclipse bus and if necessary you can
activate your life
that'll be a cutie yes in three minutes
you're going to be in a grave class okay
do this one yes I see Sergey say again
single gene in three minutes you are
going to be in Eclipse pass night class
okay copy the International Space
Station is currently flying into an
orbital sunset as you can hear from the
translated space to ground conversation
with the cosmonauts outside currently
flying 253 statute miles above central
Kazakhstan moving from Northwest to
southeast in an orbit inclined 51.6
degrees to either side of the Equator
boogity boogity Malibu beach guys and if
you don't you can question epically
eclipse class to the gills with revenge
you were in the first five minutes in
the future you can wrestle Eric solution
and then depending on how you feel of
course you can go ahead and install the
short handrail we copy all
the most angry positioning for my very
Jamaica fortune country is soft and real
will present as underneath your face
Sergey come again we didn't copy our
GoPro cameras on yes their own jingle
clothes okay
once you enter eclipse fast the
deactivator enough GoPro cameras ok will
be complicated
that's why guys I'm saying that you need
to rest for 5 minutes or you have them
come on - go go go you know sir gates
will be hard to reach that area from
over here and I'm going to turn off my
camera and for Alexei it is installed
sort of mother out people you doing with
them very good so you know when you're
close to each other you can actually
relocate it ok
work well so how do I reach it what's
the best way to reach
therefore we go to I turned off my GoPro
cam camera like papi
I make you grab a hold of the soft
handrail if I make you recording now
you can actually bend your elbow to 45
degrees
you can see my leg Alexi Panos kilowatt
business monkey in which Oliver same
bumping on handrail 1505 and please
remember to perform all operations with
the isolation container of course we're
not going to forget about that and it is
a bright color
okay thanks sounds good
step up yeah record Muslim [ __ ] okay
I'm using my left hand handrail 1505
model no official procedures and you
were holding on to handrail 1506
Brazilian 1505 is above that one so
please move up move your hand up really
loose and to the left for mr. Merkle
better do you see the handrail 1505 do
see the level yes it's right here the
other zebras are over and you know I
don't even know when the installation
angle will be if the axis the rotation
will be sufficient or not maybe it would
be better to gather the salt flats and
rail but Alex see Alex do you go ahead
you know we're going to well actually
could be handrail 1506 I think it is at
work on the phone and go okay and what
about
6018 should we try that one
this is Mission Control again this view
from the helmet camera of Alek Kononenko
the expedition 59 commander well into
the fifth spacewalk of his career in
alexey ovchinin are about to begin the
work to install a handrail that will
connect the translation path between the
poisk module on the space facing side of
the Russian segment of the International
Space Station and the Zarya module on
the earth-facing side of the Russian
segment of the complex
I forgot about a particular let me
reengage my rat tether to vet it and
rail okay wait let me get that done so
yeah okay so I'm drinking my red Devers
group of should everyone was good at
sixty eighteen eight hundred sixty
eighteen you will see some MLM workmen
okay spend why give me a minute
no just oakley serve as equal aegis
okay guys go ahead and take a
five-minute break you can't illusion
let's think it's all over and then we
will begin the handrail installation and
please rest for now
I hope you love it okay so I'm going to
attach this one to rest ever this is
number 16 love it
Oh special okay so I'm in an excellent
position now okay so we knob came off
and back with our downlink TV after a
handover between satellites on our
tracking and data relay satellite system
constellation once again this view now
from alexey ovchinin z-- helmet camera
as he and Alok kononenko work in the
vicinity of the poisk module on the
space facing side of the Russian segment
of the station one hour 11 minutes into
today's spacewalk that is scheduled to
last about six hours and twenty minutes
or so no Kononenko is in the final weeks
of his stay on orbit on the
International Space Station
he Canadian Space Agency astronaut David
saint-jacques and NASA flight engineer
and McLain are scheduled to depart the
International Space Station and their
Soyuz M s 11 spacecraft for a landing on
the steppe of Kazakhstan their
spacecraft is actually attached to the
poisk module which is in the vicinity of
where Kononenko end of Chenin are
currently working
they'll be undocking from the station on
June 24th a little less than four weeks
from now for a landing on the steppe of
Kazakhstan to wrap up a mission of two
hundred three days in duration that will
cook Kononenko in his four flights into
space at seven hundred thirty six days
in space
he will wind up sixth on the all-time
endurance list
lexy of kenan who launched a few months
ago with nick Hague to the International
Space Station will be returning on
October 3rd along with the United Arab
and
it's spaceflight participant huzzah Ali
al-mansouri who is to launch on
September 25th on a Soyuz spacecraft
from the baikonur cosmodrome with alex
corpo chika and nasa astronaut Jessica
Muir skripochka and Mir will remain
onboard the station while al-mansouri
returns home with oaktree Ninh and Hague
so crew choice okay go ahead and tighten
it and it's pushing against something
well do you see that plate over there I
think it's been a service experiment or
something so we're going to change its
position stand by
let me release it beautiful group and
again please hold it for now where is
your rail so that's how is it going to
be installed you see it sort of Bureau
of your floor actually 41 should be in
the upwards direction
Goodin you some orders how can you move
it down move it down at the Mingo
actually move it down okay
I moved it down oh okay so good for
business okay now it's working thank you
please hold it and the win knob came off
when you're sober
whoopee Aleksey can you use the handle
well you know where is this version knob
right here okay go ahead and understand
read on you go to do this be careful and
slow forgettable use small movements
some holding it potential bring okay
coffee
happiness with robotics okay so them in
there we're knob that is coming off all
the time yes and there it is again
or the signal cruiser broken case
service the range
No
so rebuttal to Zeldin okay how many
turns did you
companies across Christmas did I think
it should be closer to the Maserati wait
oh yes yes I could Aleksei what is here
reposition yourself you do think it was
better I'm trying different options here
really I think I've found the right
position so try to pull the wire
together
go great at this role I believe that it
was stowed for a long time so maybe not
flexible enough when we were trying to
simulate that on the station
we heard some noise some cracking noise
when we tried to read it on copy okay
okay I think I've put it on we will need
to remove it right here where this
handrail is all right
Jim where is it but Ramon you will
believe the wire died on it yes you will
first need to start it down correctly
so whatever they need help reduce
abortion you know for sure the hook has
moved away so we will need to reposition
everything and reconfigure everything
other thing to control issues it's not
moving all the way
for Starla videos put it on yes I did I
haven't heard a click but you will hear
it later you will need to press it right
here we were able to find where yes you
will need to press it let me try to move
closer
did you ever still look like you okay oh
okay hold it the way you're holding it
right now